lassé pts du grand versailles comprenez
communautés professionnelles et
territoriales de santé vient
officiellement de signer un accord
conventionnel avec la délégation
départementale de la rs et l'assurance
maladie
concrètement c'est un projet qui propose
différentes missions permettant
d'accéder plus facilement aux soins et
elle s'inscrit dans le cadre de la loi
ma santé 2022
mise en place par le gouvernement qui
propose des solutions face aux nouveaux
défis du système de santé français
alors là c'est pts du grand versailles a
déjà été validé par les rs au préalable
mais cette signature est la
concrétisation du projet aujourd'hui
c'est la signature du contrat officiel
on qui constitue officiellement 7c pts
et qui dit l'état donc via l'assurance
maladie vous donne un certain nombre de
financements pour mettre en oeuvre les
objectifs qui sont dans votre projet
médical le grand versailles couvre 18
communes dont 275 mille habitants qui
vont pouvoir bénéficier de ce nouveau
service de santé de ce groupement de
professionnels du territoire
ils sont sages femmes sont infirmiers
kinés ou encore podologue chacun va
continuer à voir son activité le
pharmacien la sage-femme l'infirmier le
médecin mais ils vont travailler
ensemble sur des projets communs à
monter pour faire de la coordination et
une pour pour permettre une meilleure
prise en charge du patient
l'accord officiellement signé ce 17
décembre entre la rs l'assurance maladie
et ces professionnels acte des objectifs
à atteindre sur cinq ans pour arriver à
une satisfaction aux des patients sur
l'offre de soins
il met en lumière trois missions
principales qui devront être conduites
sur le territoire c'est l'offre de soins
l'accès rapide avec des soins aux soins
non programmés nous trouver un médecin
traitant
il ya beaucoup de passion un sur dix qui
n'ont pas de médecin traitant donc
offrir un médecin traitant à ses
patients et puis la coordination entre
les professions de santé au sein du
territoire pour travailler sur ces trois
axes le groupement de professionnels de
santé serait accompagné et financé par
l'assurance maladie
la cpm a sur l'importance de soutenir ce
projet et les autres à venir grâce au
cps ont fait le pari que les patients se
note sur le territoire de notre
département seront mieux pris en charge
qu'il y aura aussi donc grâce à cette
meilleure coordination à ces échanges
entre professionnels de santé comme de
fait ils pourront avoir accès plus
facilement professionnels de santé ne
pas être en même temps dedans le dans
l'idée marc de rechercher un spécialiste
de devoir solliciter une prise en charge
à l'hôpital tout sauf ça se fera de
façon fluide et coordonnés grâce à
l'organisation il est unique et
numériques des professionnels utilisent
sur le territoire
la signature officielle de l'accord
permet à lacets pts du grand versailles
de bénéficier d'un financement sur les
cinq prochaines années une somme à
hauteur de 450 mille euros au maximum
par an